everybody what's up welcome back to
stream Coco yeah we're back we're back
it's been three long torturous weeks of
summer break for us it's been four since
we've been back here oh really miss that
first Monday Oh cuz right because our TV
is on the truck because we went to
comic-con welcome back everybody today
we are playing oh what's that do you
something where you want to say okay it
seems like years ago
Beth Morosky is with you in the chat
room Jason O'Malley creeper in the
corner welcome back everybody we're back
you know what'd be great is if we
lighten up the inset box there it feels
a little dark to me I don't know
all right word rusty guys it's been a
month we're back Astros fan 82 good to
see you
apparently Astros fan 82 got pooped on
by a seagull when they were a kid oh
there you go I got bit by a swan when I
was a kid we're never come down this
weekend yeah please tell the story Beth
maybe a pigeon and scene perfect story
SourceFed Darth it all good to see you
Cowen's my hero what's up rest in peace
Jorge what is this this is a
game compound that we're gonna play it's
an indie game by plastic Studios I did
hashtag bound don't go to that on
Instagram unless you want to see a lot
of people tied up instead bound ps4 is
ashtag you want i like indie games and
this is a new one that i've yet to play
and i am also going to turn up the
volume continues oh I take it back it's
just loud enough
I love it
we're back tonight oh we're a creepy
looking woman
Oh preggers ooh
pranks that we're gonna go into that
scary looking house
this game is bound ish talk up here Oh
looking at a nice
okay so let's play video kind of but
like we're much more professional that's
right we are a pregnant woman hey I
didn't think that's what this game would
be not look at this oh look at that like
I should walk it through the same I feel
like we should drown ourselves so
simplistic - why is this game called
bound and I'm a pregnant lady you have a
nice dress on though let's go to the
creepy house what do you think should we
go to the creepy house the lighthouse or
drown ourselves what should we do hello
Jen and why show 12 good to see you
pregnant ladies are creepy confirmed I
don't know this is an S&M game I'm not
sure
hey so Luke so Luke 1 good to see you
first comment alright we're gonna try to
drown ourselves
you guys are sick mofos but we'll do it
I feel like we should go to the creepy
house but you know what I'm gonna do
what you guys want because you determine
the course yeah what we're playing which
is always a misty yeah okay we're going
in we're gonna drop I can only walk this
fast I don't think I can do anything
else I can only walk this fast so we're
just gonna wade into the ocean no
there's water
oh that's as far as we can get as far as
we can go guys it doesn't want us to
drown ourselves let's just walk along
this water no sand gets everywhere
though sand gets everywhere
that's like oh wait a second I feel like
sometimes the screen is changing I'm
trying to walk into the ocean everybody
I love Dragon Ball games I'm Salvi 201
big fan and yes I'm gonna plays universe
two members name here it will live
several hours inside a corpse I think
they're talking about a baby that's
terrible
I mean know that oh this son we're gonna
get sunburned
this game is oh whoa whoa whoa holy crap
what is going on
the monster is destroying my kingdom
whoa is that the bad guy
wait now we're did woo only this oh look
how I run my car I run oh look at this
run whoa look how I dance oh there's a
big black box dude yes a big box
oh look at me look at me up some
property so dainty a proper O'Malley
this insane game based and your body
yeah yeah looks like I can do some
tumbles I've got ribbons coming out of
my hands and the floor is all weird I
say this floor is a lot like my kitchen
it's kind of messed up acid trip
confirms this peripheral planet Vinny
Corrado
love you too oh look at me dance we're a
mom go so is this the ocean side jump
off here I'm gonna die if I jump off we
jump down here
experiment jump oh my gosh alright well
it turned into a bunch of triangles
they're not a cat and suddenly blade
found himself in love again yeah I'm in
love with this this chick is pretty cool
I'm back on tinder by the way so that's
fine get the word out this is as weird
as tinder I would swipe right for this
it's basically the daughter of Daft Punk
oh yeah
Daft Punk daughter let's look we're in
some kind of church these are pews that
I'm jumping on ooh
destroy something I can I can roll I can
jump I can do cartwheels so it's all I
can do so let's go this way
Wow look at this dude this is bananas we
don't know what's going on yes such a
relaxing fall dear death sit undisclosed
using that was that was kind of like the
most relaxing death I've ever
experienced a game okay ooh whoa what's
going on that the QC look if this game
is crazy everything I go near like gets
all weird what's going on over there
look at that bucks animate the
animations are really well done Jeff I
agree this game is gorgeous I love it
and I've said this before I love a game
that shows me something different yeah
and this game so far is very different
oh you want could you put that mic up or
is that supposed to be pointed to we got
some issues guys good for weeks I look
at this I love the way I'm running
look at how I'm running whoo that was
just a cold open Oh weird
very cold open
this is really relaxing and fun talk
about my dancing woo-woo-woo this is
great
I'm just running I'm enjoying this WTF
yeah this is the baby in the womb and
the monsters daddies oh I'm not gonna
finish that right that's it they just
passed it today they just passed this
game today look at this oh we've got
some yeah what do we think this is let's
hear some theories this is the baby
right here's a bunch of french fries
sweet potato fries look at me dancing in
the sweet potato fries happy Monday
everybody let's dancing some fries I
feel like she should be singing the
hills are alive yeah but in like robot
poo hey I can do something if I hold the
button
I have ribbons around me look at this is
weird people holding boxes
we're in the sweet potato front fry
forest
it could be cheddar cheese this is we're
smelling in a game would really help us
AG you know forget the Oh God
I almost fell off forget oculus rift man
let's let's get something going on we
can smell a game yeah what do you think
this smells like pink lavender probably
this probably smelly its most delicious
what's in the box exactly what's in the
box ready alright we're gonna tip to
across this the animation of this
character is fantastic this is a
beautiful looking game entertain us Nora
I am entertaining you do you think this
is do you guys like my t-shirt today it
says take me to your drug dealer because
I am addicted to methamphetamine it's
just a truth yeah hold l2 to run move
look at me run look at me run this is
great I'm so graceful this might be the
most graceful character I've ever played
in the game if you're watching youtube
go to twitch because youtube is iffy
right Oh YouTube went down not a good
way you know I'm saying that's what's up
that's what's up
[Music]
no MBLAQ WL says the South Park crew are
working on a smell attachment for their
upcoming game that's possible I love
that there's pleasure no she hasn't been
cursed with the Blair jeans ooh look oh
my God look at me just go across this
I'm just doing everything with style I'm
gonna oh look at this well I'm like I'm
just walking around the office like this
just like arms out like this is great I
ever made plastic Studios whoever's idea
was to make this a ballerina is awesome
look at me just rolling along forget
Nathan Drake and he's like my long
elastic Studios this Webber girl do you
what it is a ballerina mill is awesome
someone said we look like we could be
just rolling along forget ya
the most feared country in the world and
their technologically advanced they all
look like this it's awesome we're taking
over they're called the nation it's
badass east of West look it up great
comic book oh my god now here's the
thing how am I supposed to destroy
anything because all I have are blue
ribbons am I gonna dance them to death
look at me like this is
look at me just spin around like a beast
alright let's go oh there's some kind of
thing up here ooh wait what's this I'm
supposed to do there we go
whoa cool can I jump that far I feel
like oh here's this one over here oh I
can double jump yeah oh this is awesome
whoa look at this holy crap this game is
awesome why though are does everything
break when I touch it it's just like my
real life it's just so my real life I
burned myself real bad trying to iron my
pants today guys yeah it was bad I was
like making oatmeal the gnome I was
gonna fall over and I grabbed the iron
it really hurt I love this I love seeing
the generate and upload PDI files
O'Malleys putting out all this weird as
if this game isn't weird enough we're
getting like weird like coding just
everything doesn't have to be about
killing ballerina lives matter there you
go how does my hair it's when I should I
live off green screen video he's is it
Iver Oh guys bone Iver came out with a
couple new songs I'm gonna go see those
guys
Hollywood boy oh yeah I got my tickets
I'm waiting the back oh is that true
well guys there's so much cheese below
as I'm nervous
death by cheese though actually not that
bad to be honest that you just
confidently like a boss like a ballerina
boss uh look at all those delicious
fries I can't eat fries so this is those
are my enemy I think these ladders are
dope oh wow
are we gonna find a monster at some
point you still plan this yeah MeJA
Emmanuel Blair it when you said fix wait
can you hold on oh no where's man you
said fix the mic the YouTube stream died
everything you touch is destroyed
including lives Thor
thora thumb including lives I've been on
tinder for eight hours no matches so far
who this is pretty wait that looks like
a monster though over there well nervous
how do we protect ourselves I think
that's the blue I think that's the blue
thing Oh what's this whoa this is cool
oh wait there's there's black ones can I
just jump if I jump
[Music]
that's different wait it's like a chess
piece this dude looks like a dick
oh god I knew this was gonna be too easy
what is happening now there's the table
what's going on
this game would be doping VR whoa what's
happening whoa what's this what what the
f
you know what this guy does look like a
monster this guy looks like a real jerk
it's a terrible dad
[Music]
what is happening as I backup it
discipler
I should I wait should I go in this way
oh it's a memory somebody's saying it's
a memory of what aren't I supposed to be
in the womb was I supposed to press but
I didn't press any buttons yeah this
deserves new expansion pack it's our mom
thing I didn't destroy the guy this game
is dope Molly Baker you're wrong
[Music]
hmm I'm such a good dancer just say if
you're hiding in the deep find him and
convince him to help us why don't you do
something huh MA what's up
I maybe it's my hand the child is the
Antichrist
that's primal seven I like where your
head's at
can I back up forever yeah exactly
where's the Levi there's a great comic
book not comic but just comic strip very
tux to my heartstrings which you can
only go for it's called like you can
only go forward it's awesome it's kind
of about video game as well as about
life it's really great order can you
google it uh we only go forward comic
strip ooh I think these are like jelly
tiles Oh
oops oops oops okay okay I see I see
wait we only can we only go forward
comics oh yeah that's what it yeah
that's one of these things it's not
YouTube though go for that yeah it's
that one it's an altered yeah guys it's
a great comic strip you should all read
it right go down go down
oh yeah that's great that's what it is
altered love altered guys
that's looking a great comic in the it's
a good thing good nice little shot of
life to start off your foot you're
making Monday it's going on here you are
gonna start crying it's great yeah let's
let's start a new thing called weepy
Mondays when we start them every Monday
with just weeping this is a gorgeous
game oh man wait what's that wait is
that the guy that's the big monster dude
oh god what are we just gonna be just
chillin I'm just gonna start doing this
in the office okay leave these moves
like these moves that's right exactly
what would be the Olympic sport you
would do best at who's reading quietly
to yourself yeah that's a good one
I already doing weeping Mondays has lost
interest yeah you know yeah some of us
are ahead of the game on weeping
Monday's not Aleph alliteration you
misery Monday's multi you're right the
misery Monday's is way better weepy
Wednesday yeah I don't know if I talked
about this before but I'm gonna talking
about it now just the fact that our
commissary and here at Warner Brothers
and the Warner Brothers lot in Burbank
California
nine one five two two there's it took
zip code our look at this beautiful game
I wonderful ever gonna make it over
there the Kama Sutra brothers line - oh
jeez oh my god does this thick oh no I
don't want to go down does this thing
where it's they have different meals
like you know what I'm saying like
females like every Thursday is like
Thanksgiving yeah all right on Fridays
they do we think they have a stir-fry
meal right they have a stir-fry meal now
they could make it walk Wednesday's okay
they could make it
stir-fry days right instead it's on
Friday and it's called wok Fridays
what the
Wednesday is like like the lettuce cups
yeah what are you doing what are you
doing
what Fridays is so wrong and then this
is not a joke by the way
Monday's guess what they have Mondays
taco Mondays I swear to God I swear to
you
taco Mondays wok Fridays I'm gonna
commit a murder I'm gonna commit a
murder it's so easy it's in the name
everybody has who has taco Mondays sorry
I just got really angry but it does make
me crazy we're just going down I didn't
know what's happening we're probably to
go to the cube seeing it kill we are
going to go to the cube see you get
killed oh no actually we're going down
and do this thing okay I just want to be
like she's walking around it is the
worst oh my god
I just can't stand it you guys I mean at
least Thursdays they have they have they
got the Thanksgiving thing right yeah
but also like you know what Thanksgiving
is it's special if it's every week part
of the thing that makes things seem
special is its annual you have to wait a
year yeah exact all about only enjoying
yourself and small person otherwise how
do you know you're writing otherwise
you're happy or something okay we got a
beam I'm not quite sure what we're
supposed to do here I love this
aesthetic though I'm into this plastics
to do is well done
we still have figured out what this does
by the way the charged up situation oh
then we can do some dope other moves
okay I jump in here what am I supposed
to do here should I jump down here
what is that lay they're gonna kill us
or it's gonna transport us somewhere you
just apply for a sub button yet now we
have it we just need to do that I'm
gonna jump down in this weird thing
right this is gonna kill or waste should
I go over here more there's nothing over
here but dead dead stuff hey Tory AM
what's up jump jump alright I'm jumping
in oh look at this
Hey look at this hey look at this oh hey
look at this oh look at me oh man this
game is cool this game is so weird and
cool look at this oh man we're going
down some kind of crazy passage doing
the music's change into something cool
okay can I swing
oh I can jump oh geez oh no oh no oh I
killed us
I killed us I'm back I'm back everybody
do a little stretching this piece we
want to take yoga yeah
we're on this is so cool I don't think
I'm supposed to be going all the way
down here though right
oh maybe I am does this open up no this
seems bad right I'm going back down I'm
going down it's open up here we go
whoo weird I'm on the floor I'm sorry
bye wha I'm surrounded by QB water whoa
there's cubes all around me this is
insane you guys I just want to talk to
the creator of this game would be like
bro or girl what's up this is I think
I'm not supposed to I think I'm supposed
to like go there any other place am I
supposed to go here I'm gonna die if I
jump out right we're all agreed yeah
man Mike is clipping pretty hard sorry
you seen this for Cirque de Soleil where
the pregnant lady go I don't know Liz
Lyra cash rules everything around me bro
where's Bob Ross where's Conan Conan is
in his office right now shooting
something
I had to try guys I think we're not
supposed to be at the bottom I think
we're supposed to go up and like jump
over somewhere don't you think can I
let's do a little testing of moves yeah
that's wrong this thing we're close to
the ground let's do some testing abuse
this this this does nothing this does
nothing whoo what's this what is this
when I do this there's a blue thing on
the floor right what is this - oh the
blue plath on the floor oh here it is
okay ah thank you who said that blue
path on the floor
[Music]
smiling dinosaur laughs could you guys
please please just livestream you guys
shoot the bit the clothes came with
Conan we've talked about doing that um
maybe maybe like right before I mean the
thing is like I don't want to ruin it I
want to keep the jokes I don't want you
guys you know unfortunately you know
it's it's a different thing also I will
say this is kind of weird but like the
fact that no one is watching us yet
means we can take more chances and be
funnier this is like we are performing
for you of performing I'm sorry but like
it's different it's a different energy
and I wouldn't want the end result of
clueless gamer to be affected by the
fact we were performing for people live
it's just a different kind of experience
but maybe oh yeah
Clara clean clay Davis thinking about it
that mother character said the guy is
supposed to be in the deep you're right
this is the deep dude oh the bottom of
the Kyuubi ocean someone said oh yeah
yeah that's true hmm look at this who is
this this is a this is a divorce
attorney my father
I mean look she's cute I would she's
cute maybe a little young for me though
I love no face ladies the kingdom's
already gone oh no whoa hold our to
button and other combinations to dance
dance our way through the pain I don't
know what I'm doing here
dance via life
well
what happened what we danced go wave on
the ocean romance no face ladies
definitely a swipe right for play that's
right ladies if you don't have a face
call me up let's talk what would you
like to see you in a no face is tinder
profile ooh um dislikes faces yeah cuz
you know likes not having a face
dislikes yeah would be good you know
that favors me clearly there's no
smelling I know weird so they can't
smell my weirdness humans Oh what's
going on up here
aliens that's truly infrared
she's like more developed that's true
probably not but that's a good that's
nice this is crazy what's going on up
here all these little bugs and stuff
this is like Star Trek beyond over
[Music]
I'm not sure that look at this what the
what is this whoa Oh No
Oh hold r2 to dance and free myself this
is great freed I just want some George
Michael to feed myself oh but I'm back I
treat myself it's good this thing
this game is cool I gotta say I'm having
more fun playing this than no man's sky
unfortunately back wait so the dude
didn't help us the deep the guy from the
deep didn't help us at all
he just said dance where's that big
monster dude oh my shadow what the heck
whoa that's cool all right wait says you
wait hold on I want to learn how to do
this quickly look at how sexy I am on
the wall though just sexing it up on the
wall okay let's see l2 to run right okay
so I'm gonna run I like this idea see if
I can jump over yeah don't oh I went
through oh I got killed by a bunch of
weird bugs dance it out dancing away
dance dance my girl dance let's go
destroy these things
dance dance dance think these moves
though we're dancing it up guys dance it
up primal seven dance it out it's it out
loccent winch whirs were dancing it I'm
not sure what's going on a rep supposed
to do what if I stopped dancing never
said no we're okay
all these things oh no that you'd
actually have to keep dancing
Shirin supposed to do here all these
things are trying to hurt us but the
dance is saving us guys I did go to this
did I tell you one thing I did over the
three week break cuz I went to this all
in the dark dance party it's all the
dark I don't understand who I'm in
someone oh yeah oh geez Oh Pete's I
don't know is this is that good or bad
what's happening I can't tell us that
the dance is protecting us though all
right oh no it's ah screw you dad Oh Oh
the mom and the dad are fighting
Oh oh no she's gonna kill I know how
this ends it's gonna be very bad
yeah
[Music]
oh whoa and now we're reading a book oh
this is something that she's created in
her head well she's a terrible artist
I'm sorry it's just true I hate to do
this but guys made her dance okay the
little girls sad and because her so the
little girl gets up she drowns I think
that's the mom the mom and then all the
triangle Dorito things are attacking her
there's a but yeah I'm really hungry
this is a bad game to fling you're
hungry and then there's there's a bed
with flying TVs of course and then well
you got your tree happening ectoplasmic
111 well you can make sense of it if you
try to look at it allegorically I always
love with stories are kind of weird it
makes them less boring to me I agree and
I love this game so far
books are dope I agree with you too
you're a terrible artist a trustee of
your gaming I am at work the dad's got
to be the bad guy I don't know a Tetsuo
maybe the dad's not the bad guy by the
way it could be an old boyfriend there's
a kid who drew a plant and there's a
bunch of paper airplanes that are sweaty
okay just so we're on the same page the
paper airplanes with a couple
butterflies and a cat help out the
mother daughter Daft Punk do oh yeah oh
we reach the end of the book wait let's
go back was there anything before the
first page
Doritos chip Dorito chip - he doesn't it
I think quite likes work eyes exactly
it's a weed plant that's weed dude the
book was better it's this kind of hooker
hat
well how do we put this book away wait
wait wait where is it oh there's an X oh
oh we're looking wait did we just go
back it does feel a lot like Blue's
Clues they want to do a life of drugs in
the future there's a war between the
computers and humans and the dog the cat
I knew it when they your kingdom will
come I should've done the paper airplane
oh no she's tired of wearing her kingdom
whoa she gave me a pearl necklace get
your mind out of the gutter
my conan's dad no I'm not uh-huh
wait our dress is different now we have
an orange dress and now we're green you
have any other cool moves nope the same
moves but look all these beads
everywhere if blue can do it we can't
you yeah now there's a circle and now
there's a white box this game is whack
oh it's a level selection screen zoom to
the page you can play this what's the
story is behind it ah thank you hand a
Vivek you can play each level in any
order to our changes
whoa cool whoa there's a box that's
following us so wait maybe we went too
far
are we going down into the deep again oh
not that way
then I just kill myself
no bees yes death night I am Conan's
living punching bag that is correct my
straps have bad acid or some good acid
man this is actually a pretty good trip
is anything actually happened yet says
James Tony
well we fought a monster we saw a father
the wallpaper is different oh we read a
book we're going along the wall all sexy
like look at me dance along the wall
though check out you want to see a cool
dance ooh make me go this way I do like
this dance deep to do to do dude I'm
definitely gonna dance more in the
office that's it that's the thing I'm
gonna be doing a lot more of this yeah
exactly this is awesome look at this
plastic spheres great job at making this
game it's awesome you guys are just
joining us for playing the indie game
bound by plastic Studios it's really fun
and cool and totally insane
but in a good way being surrounded by
things
Oh Ethan James 1993 I'm I'm definitely
hoping to do another throwback gamer
with the consoles you mentioned be
awesome
do it Aaron dance for Conan let's go in
this do we just come out of the store a
time door not quite sure where I'm
supposed to go there's a bunch of hot
dogs on the wall look at this part oh
you know what I think can I roll
nope oh I see there's the door here I'm
supposed to go through right wait oh we
jump over here
can we come this way no nope oh wait
these things are dicks remember I think
those things are dicks to us wait this
is the way we came up oh no no no it's
not no it's not it's definitely whoa
oh god it's making me sick oh god here
we go
this game is awesome I'm seriously into
this game guys you played the game
inside it's amazing inside is so fun I
actually didn't want to play it on the
stream because I actually wanted to
experience it it was super fun
of course Tallis thank you for joining
us I'm gonna run through this beads
quick dodge also my is way more
intense now my dancing yeah just way
better dance it uhh
get away from me bees dance away be some
of the dance these bees away ah see now
what are these this is all beef jerky
yeah it's gone from cheese to beef jerky
I know how to feel about it let's go
there's anything in these beef jerky I
should be looking for oh it does look
like there's something over here doesn't
it maybe not so much beef jerky you know
the thing is though the grease from most
beef jerky I think would ruin my dress
yeah shout out to all the ladies who got
beef jerky stains on their dresses this
weekend yeah it happens all of us some
of us like me more than most
how would you get a beef jerkey stain
out asking for a friend
burn the article of clothing by the food
okay mid sense what's happening here
with these things but I'm into it let's
get up on this can't do it I like to
dance
dude I like this dance but it boot boot
boot so how do you guys live I have
relevance to Conan and I love the show
hot topic that is asking well I've
worked for Conan since oh one that's
right that you never left
oh it's this again this oh god this
stuff is everywhere what are you what
you're feeling up polka dots polka dots
over it I mean I disagree I think we
need more more I'm gonna charge up here
dance past this
get off me get off me
dance it out let's get through this
thing dance dance your butt off dance
dance dance
dude look at us just dancing our way
around this weird pulsating Mardi Gras
beads nope you're trying then ain't
gonna work I can see you're all on top
of me if I'm just dancing my way around
yep that's right
do your best to your were stations
still let's get paid clay unfortunately
we give her a fake check everyone and we
tell her it goes into her bank account
dance goddammit dance I can't quite
figure out what's happening with quick
dodge
goddamn bees get off me there's music
playing which is making me nervous
these bees need to get off my jock oh
damn it
fell into the cube thing this game Lord
of wolves is called bound it's my
plastic Studios it's really fun it's
completely insane but we're having a
good time playing it it's nutsy cuckoos
I'm not sure what the point is of this
level exactly we're supposed to be
finding our own Kingdom I guess
yeah how do we kill myself I don't get
from ribbon to ribbon you know gb Zilla
this is uh the game is called bound is
there a new show tonight yes there is al
franken our old pal Al Franken's on the
show senator Al Franken by Daniel Brooks
is this evening gardener Schwartz how do
i but what if I can I swing this way I
look great on this thing yeah I'm a
little nervous about jumping from thing
to thing but let's try it there we go
did it oh that's not cool
whoa you know the good thing about this
game is if there's a glitch you would
never know I gotta just take a little
tapper ooh you know
I'm just killing myself guys dancing on
pink ribbons is harder than it looks
sorry Oh shite oh these pink ribbons you
guys they're so slippery that's what you
know that's what you don't realize about
the pink ribbons in Greece
they've been greased it's all that beef
jerky grease from wandering around beef
jerky forest yeah there we go perfect
alright great now we're back where we
belong with our weird cubes and be
friends I think we're collecting these
cubes and we're gonna construct our own
so where's that going why it's all
flying away going somewhere oh this
looks like a dangerous forest full of
moldy french fries and bees and nervous
about this
Just Dance it out you know dance it out
y'all dance it out dance it out dance it
out how high do you be do you enjoy this
game super high oh wait let's go over
here what is going on over here with
this stuff if I let go I'm just gonna be
oh look it's all turning to white what
are these like black chocolate chips
little chocolate shards ooh we don't
were in here now Oh understand this at
all the music is making me nervous
oh no I mean this again I'm in that
weird let's go let's go let's go let's
just run away look at it oh man I went
through that nothing happened alright
here we go
I can't really see what's going on okay
dodge through this let me just dance in
my way I'm so excited and I just can't
hide it you know what I'm saying guys
you feeling me the Flashdance tip all
right we got some weird smoke /of
music's dying some Bad's about to happen
dude
it's like a car wash in the ninth
dimension yeah oh Jesus Christ what is
happening now I'm on a big ball dude
what is up this game is bananas this is
crazy town this is amazing I'm so I feel
sick to my stomach
this is awesome this game is so fun all
right here we go
yeah no guys what is up really you know
what is up and down they're just they're
just concepts we've created you know to
make sense of this world they're not
absolutes yeah you know what they're not
absolutes I might even go on the right
way we're them good one
[Music]
whoo this is gonna turn to dark souls
but harder yeah no kidding wait let's
get on this big ribbon how do I get on
that big ribbon oh my god ah mayonnaise
mostly mayonnaise mayonnaise and spackle
oh wait here we go a lot of mayonnaise a
lot of spackle should I go this way back
to the bees or should I go up here the
staircase of the bees you guys so
disoriented yes I'm getting all Jaden
Smith on y'all all right mirrors her
eyes are eyes really windows to the soul
yeah Conan hits me all the time Alex
although now you know he started hitting
me less and throwing me into walls
that's his new thing you see if there's
a cabinet nearby he'll pick me up and
throw me into mmm
definitely the wall thing he's also
throwing shoes at me lately which is a
big thing yes stairs haven't seen stairs
let's go up the stairs do you like my
song doo doo doo doo is that you dude
that's me singing right now yeah that's
me that's me but it might be the game
might be me singing no
wait you know what I think I'm supposed
to be getting these little fragments
does it seem like that it does seem like
that I'm going back to the fragments go
back for the frags
well then schlong congratulations well
done hold the door Oh lavender you
trying to break my heart
see I think we're trying to get all
these little pieces of stuff to create
our own Kingdom you know I need to play
Soul Calibur 5 with Conan Lewis game
recruit yourselves you know Vanessa
actually we should tweet that out some a
couple fans made an amazing match up
between me and Kohn and fighting each
other
in real life and in Soul Calibur it's
pretty dope they did a really good job
it's awesome all right
the people the offices next to us Peters
no no there's the monster again you dig
I hate this guy
he likes balls what's happening oh
what's up now it's Britney
are you gonna try throw those balls at
me yup probably well I'm gonna dance it
out I can't hear you I can't hear you go
ahead get all you want all you want I'm
dancing it up can't hurt me hurt me I'm
dancing near me yeah run away run
away back into your ocean blocks that's
right run away cuz I'm dancing and I
can't be stopped
alright are we getting back on the balls
the balls are pretty fun I gotta say I
think we should get back on the balls
let's do it ball jumping we're doing
some ball jumping y'all oh whoa
that was crazy I don't know where I'm
going anymore wait I'm trying to get up
to this thing
let's keep our eyes on the prize here we
want to get up to over there I think
Wow look at that all right
oh gosh I can't how do you fall off one
of these I don't know if you can he says
right before he falls off it's music is
dope I'm loving this game oh this looks
guys there's some more blue pizza's here
grab grab blue pieces see I'm definitely
constructing something on the blue
pieces I touch guys this is gonna be my
Halloween costume like what is your deal
look at this this is something it feels
like oh do you think this looks like
something what if I dance here I danced
here nothing happens but that's also the
loading screen so I'm not sure what's
going on there all right later brother
Todd three balls I like going on the
ball Spence you know I did love balls of
all kinds
there's some weird laughing this is
gonna be bad weather this is it's a
bunch of bees oh it's a portrait or
something a portrait of something it
looks like a a guy thinking kind of
doesn't it a lot of beat a lot of balls
dance it out girl uh-oh oh no it's
another one of those things where our
dad is being a dick to us
look wait there's a ball what's he mean
memories like the corner of alright it's
an office this game is awesome by the
way this game is gorgeous agree gamer
Walt oh yeah what up Rob revenge
surly duck that someone should do a
cosplay Aaron Beth can't cosplay just
make sure I'm weeping whoa what's
happening oh wait oh the mom the mom's
mad at the dad that busted Oliver oh
yeah you know what she said she's
like I don't want this kingdom anymore
oh this marriage the kingdom's the
marriage dude that's what it is the dads
destroying the marriage but it's the mom
to blame though maybe the dads not the
bad guy cuz the dad looks he looks like
he's afraid here doesn't he what is he
saying
I want a divorce this is crazy you know
what I bet the dad had an affair but go
find the monster the monster would be
like the other woman and kill her and
get her
what's up Darius is Adi abusive
relationship you're right nope just be
stop fighting all right well oh yeah
look at this cuz here's the kid over
here
wait this is us when we were a kid the
pregnant the pregnant woman the pregnant
woman is the blonde woman is the blonde
girl
[Music]
oh and she saw her parents fighting and
they got a divorce
look at this though I love those models
who's your girl have some good toys over
here a lot of balls hey wait a second
what is that doesn't this look like the
room we were in kind of well look at all
these balls and then there's and there's
this big ribbon here that's kind of like
hey look at all these Hey look wait look
we were in rhythmic gymnastics or
something
you know yeah we were trophies in
rhythmic gymnastics this kid is a
terrible artist this is this is an awful
picture that's that's a scary ass doll
15.2 the Rif wait a second so maybe oh
look at this wait something's broken
oh no it's train tracks wait it's like
we're taking a it's like we're running
around our memories
the beads on the mom's necklace were
like the ball things that we're dumping
oh yeah you're right Oh badness I do
anything here so you know what maybe the
story is since we're having a kid we're
yeah we're thinking about all the
that went wrong in our childhood this
game is dope the book what about the
book they're fighting the kids room
yeah the beats floating there are the
giant balls Oh Taylor says in the last
level when she said find the helper in
the darkness it was her brother oh yeah
okay see it's all starting to make sense
guys I love this game these are the
beads that have gone everywhere dance it
out dance it baby dance it out five eye
beads so what am I going to dance oh
here and all the beads are becoming I
think they're all disappearing
this is how we found solace which is a
word that means peace here we got the
big ribbon
oh yeah man killing the game just and I
think I know everything about this game
it turns into a dope Tron light-cycle on
a ribbon over a cube see dude I'm moving
this is awesome oh my god you guys whoa
the ribbons like being made as we're on
it yeah this is insane you got me great
wait stop
oh my god this is the craziest drug trip
ever
[Music]
Wow this team is awesome
here we go right back to the beginning
ooh ooh Oh another memory uh uh oh man
this isn't gonna be cool Oh
[Music]
you feel like there's got to be some
kind of abuse right I don't want to say
it but I feel like not gonna be oh hey
why are we littering dude we're getting
up what is going on in this game I guess
it's late in the day
wait no I'm the pregnant lady again
which is the reality you guys I know we
can't drown ourselves but I'm gonna try
again just to see what happens hmm
Jarvis has experienced a loss of ego
boundaries what does that mean
that's graphic water is cold
can you walk in nope should we go back
to the car wait what is going on I'm so
confused
I thought we're gonna play the rest of
these levels can I run will let him walk
faster can I dance though yeah dancing
okay a bit faster Shane I know Kronos in
Korea last party going anywhere soon I
hope so because we had such a good time
in Korea first thing to try drowning oh
here we go oh Sh you were walking up to
the house
no sprint button dude she's she's
pregnant dude oh yeah this could be
where we grew up
oh wait now we're on the bench I would
have sat on the bench first cuz I'm
pregnant
alright let's get back in which one
should we do I feel like we did that one
we did these levels I think right let's
go to like the last one all right what's
this one that's a bunch of throw-up came
out of a box
this one was yeah oh you know what wait
a second wait a second wait a second
what's on the front in the back of the
page is what it is so like look at this
so like this side is on the right side
of the monster right on the other side
is her
right on this side is like the TV saying
all kinds of bad stuff on the other side
it was all the dreamers like this side
is it's a big weird tree I pick them
wrong button glared Jesus Christ this
side it's a tree and on the other side
it's just a plant wait let's do the tree
one good in there unless we chose the
bed it's hard to tell what's going on I
think it would be the tree I think it's
gonna be a big dead by daylight you know
what we're gonna play dead by daylight
next week that game is supposed to be
awesome what am I doing here
whoa he's like my bad sorry you've done
maybe her yeah maybe her
brother is to be the evil one we have to
fix it you touched it now you have to
fix it I don't want to do this though
because this stuff you touch it traps
you
I knew it I knew I was getting a tagged
nope dance it out ain't touching me it's
a tree giant tree there we go
filler buddy see no I'm not worrying a
very same shirt I'm wearing a shirt that
says take me to your drug dealer because
I'm addicted to methamphetamine it's
less like a joke and more just the truth
David of my addiction all right I'm
still think collecting these things is a
good idea right collecting these weird
blue things oh boy there's a lot of
these weird bad tentacles around here I
look a little prancing this girl is a
great dancer you know what I'm making a
prediction I think what's gonna happen
is towards the end of this game the
weirdness is gonna start to bleed into
the real world and then she's gonna go
crazy
and then her baby's gonna come out it's
not like this that's my prediction
mmm-hmm I just feel like this dad should
be the music like the Reading Rainbow
music or something
the skirt is outstanding I agree
odd drugs the problem the solution to
all the world's problems and solutions
thank you what is in the middle should
we go for the middle this stuff one of
those weird things what do you think ah
I'm just stretching or bleh maybe she's
in the real world and prancing around an
asylum but this is what she sees the
baby comes out dancing of course it's a
morbid prediction morbid but alright
I'm gonna I'm gonna do a little module a
jumper ooh do the jump oh that's how you
do it yeah perfect nailed it I hate
everything about this game I must know
how to I love everything about this game
and also must know it oh that's a big
one oh Jesus kill myself oh I definitely
want to get that there's only one of
them annoying this is gonna be bad news
I did get most of them though can I get
those over there
what do you think it's gonna be tough
let's roll right off it's hard to time
that it and plus this game the mechanics
are a little weird and the jumping
is kind of tough this is a SIA video do
that see a videos nope I just saw that
Ruthie white one of our producer showed
me that video and it's amazing it's not
fall off
[Music]
what if I go this way I only got these
blocks dancing to death 10 huh 19 it's
gonna be a little tricky but I think we
can do it
and by tricky I mean I'm the worst at
this 10 out of 10 8 out of 10
get it
damnit I don't think this game is
Japanese is it it's polish all the best
things I don't know if I'm even getting
these blocks if you die if it me even
matters but I've died chill at a time so
I don't kind of get that last one I
can't god this is so tough
I don't know if it saves the blocks aI
don't know what the blocks do B I don't
know if you die if it's saving the
blocks or not you know
but I got him this good happens I feel
like the blocks are kind of instrumental
into what I'm supposed to be doing well
that looks quavery over there let's go
that way The Witcher is polish also yeah
polish make some good games man
can i play something else is your ax no
I'm sorry we're not gonna play something
else this game is awesome but next week
we will play something else
you turn the blocks in and receive beef
jerky you know what that would be
awesome is it bad if I just eat beef
jerky is up like a whole meal is that
good or bad
also the colors seem very much like a
chill a child's room doesn't that seem
like a
what's going on here we're gonna go in a
liquorice tunnel does this work
I got it stop dying here guys what's
going on y'all
there we go alright we're on a delicious
churro path of churros you know we play
this game before lunch because all we
talk about is food
protein exactly walljumps yeah this is a
fun game Phenom II nailed it
yeah this game I agree this is not by
methods this is a people who do acid
much friendlier the music is freaking me
out a minute back alive
oh come on really the last Jareau movie
idea the last chair Oh guys I saw
sausage party it's really funny and I
saw hell or high water it's also really
funny and great teller high waters great
movie one of the best I've seen in a
long time
Penn Foster is so funny here we go uh-oh
looks like a dad and a lazy boy chair
doesn't it yeah it's about to go down
shoots about to go down the last chair
is the most serious that's true vide
Holly oh there's our brother
she's gonna help me or not Oh
[Applause]
what a lazy a hole my fault how is it my
fault gonna dance the night away
where do you go you fell into the sea
like a turd yeah that's a great dance
moves in this game oh here we go
yep push it up and let's go
here's the ball dance your best dance
your best dance a girl did your best
dete your best dancing frickin masculine
dancing dance way out I'm so excited I'm
so scared
here we go Oh up here now know where
we're gonna go to y'all I jump down here
and I move it over
splits
let's go let's go dance it up get your
but uh yes this is an indie game
it's called bound it's my plastic studio
since Tim I'm loving it I'm loving on it
loving me some bound don't by the way
going the hashtag bound on Instagram
because there's a lot of people tied up
I mean unless you like watching people
get tied up
I like these little I wish I'd more I
will say I do have one gripe about this
game
I wish there are more breakdancing moves
I like oh yeah I like poletik beletic
sure little ballistic but we got the
fire doesn't hurt me cuz I'm dancing it
out that's right fire just try you can't
get past my sweet dancing dance dance
dance in your face I wish
there's more breakdance E but you know I
do appreciate a good ballerina dance now
I'm down here on the walls I mean all
over these walls let me run it on these
walls
la la la la la la no no to the QVC QVC
oh but then I get up but I do a little
yolks
little sweet yoga then I'm up here oh
this is so trippy this gave me so insane
I love it I love that's one thing that
kind of blew me away the first time I
played Super Mario Galaxy was the like
running like around little planets and
stuff was like awesome like where you
don't there's no up or down really
there's no true true north if you will
whoa here what I want to know what the
tentacle oh boy well now we're getting
crazy oh my god this is like MC Escher
this is awesome just what I thought this
game couldn't get any more trippy go
this way Charlie going this way
hey boxes popping up on the bottom
right away I have no idea what's
happening by the way
oh this looks wait I can go down here
oh I'm on a platform I cannot tell
what's going on I'm just dancing my butt
off just dance it just dance it out
when in doubt dance guys that's true for
life - yeah that's great
oh please don't fall off here we are I
think this looks like a main boss if you
will you can't fricking stop the dance
this game is so weird it's so fun and so
insane just keep on dancing y'all
confusion meter maxed just twirling
around lalalala
give me them blue stuff wait can I go up
here man we got more of these ribbon
this is like the weirdest episode of
American Ninja Warrior ever music though
we're on the top of it what now
I'm a dance Oh see I got this I
got those beads oh Jesus Christ
think grow push the box
where's that box
puts the box does the guy's a dick we
all know
with that box push that box push that
back look at how cool I pushed that box
though I do it with dance guys I do it
with style that's how I live my life
style later Hey he's busy
let's go
none other than it is crazy crazy thank
you here this way Oh
beef jerky forest right through the beef
jerky for us know that local oh is that
in front of me Oh something maybe it's
her pushing like a dresser against oh
who ever said that's very smart
you're right boss and twitch first knows
what's up yeah guys we're deciphering
this game oh oh wait a second I
take that back I take that back
guys
this is gonna be awful so how does this
work okay
dad I can already tell this is gonna
take
I look the design of this game it also
kinda reminds me that movie the cell
number that crazy movie but the Jennifer
Lopez and Vincent D'Onofrio oh now we're
in this again
Jesus oh my god this is great
everything's fine
just keep going straight and
let's jump through here yeah oh great
did it I see more beads and we're
about to dance for our lives guys get
ready dance dance dance dance that's
right dance fight blobbing us dance
dance dance can't stop me and what
happens here exactly jump up in this or
something I fell down with me to this
should get on one of these things
I feel like I'm supposed to get in here
alright can I jump on one of these
things and then what I go down see see
doesn't part for me this time I
definitely do this
what happens if I just let this thing go
down that's all it does I don't know if
I could I don't know a specific
oh it's like
I don't know I guess I just should be
patient
let's be patient see that it is going
down the level is definitely sinking
right oh those things kill me after a
minute if anybody has any tips on this
part it really appreciated hold on she's
gonna kill her
maybe you know what oh here's an idea
okay jump onto this thing oh it goes
back up
change wise continuously Oh got it
oh you know what I might be old dancing
ribbon I think on the ribbon I can if I
do a left thing there's a thing I can do
on here that I've done before here is it
this no this button I can't really dance
on here wait I gotta get past this part
what time is it 10 minutes can we do it
in 10 minutes what do we think we do
here guys there is a move
what is the move is it this move there
is a move that is it dodge oh this is it
is this gonna do anything
it does feel like we're supposed to be
like changing things right I'm so
confused here
you know what let's do this orange wall
orange wall you can't swim anywhere
taller can you get off my jock orange
wall all right
oh wait the blue blue is where we
normally go right there's blue and
there's orange I'm gonna go to the blue
wall the lard yeah I don't know if I can
jump on the large cube though down there
though there's a different colored cube
is there I don't know have I seen it
difficult you bet there's one big one
I see the big one we can't jump on that
though I don't think yeah we can't jump
on the big cubes that doesn't work
the orange wall thing is there's a blue
one the blue one normally has been good
does
none of these think oh there is a
different color
oh I see I'm supposed to get on the one
of those that seems impossible but it
would make sense we need to go somewhere
we can dance what about if I do this if
I charge up my dancing right I charge up
my dope dancing and then I jump on that
thing and go down he'll still be I'm not
protected so I get to that point and I
die you have any ideas this is pretty oh
so mister I would stay in the room above
and explore that a little bit Morris's
acara's alright let's do that
there is see look there's a blue and an
or oh you know what maybe we're supposed
to do something where we push one of
these down or something you know you
don't like touch it or something get off
my jockey dick
oh you know what wait didn't come in
that way oh you know what maybe we just
go out that way maybe that's not the
right way at all that ways did
we come through here oh no all right so
I guess that was just there was
something down there for sure that we
were supposed to do that we're not doing
by the way you know I'm gonna go test
that blue wall it's bothering me
oh I can't it disappears alright well
that's it
I do want to dance it up I also want to
get the staircase in the next 50
minutes so I'm just gonna kind of a half
block all this stuff what are the ten
rules represent that's what I want to
know that's something bad
daddy's searching fingers sorry
that's Curtis even for good okay
all right here we go a lot of beef jerky
we got a beef jerky wall I'm twerking it
out bro
yeah trying to get on you kid I'm a jock
not gonna work I'm a girl jock this is
gonna whatever is gonna happen here is
gonna be terrible all right this is
insane
where do I go here let's go over this
way shall we
nope I'm protected from the
going to that ladder still dancing it
out can't get me can't get me let's get
this ladder dude I love these ladders
blue stuff we love blue stuff me and I
wish I was this cool dope this is
probably like how she sees herself right
should I get up on this thing this is
yeah this feels like can I get on this
humping the block that's great
perfect that's what I want to do sorry
kids Oh blue stuff
oh this is what is this hmm this gonna
be it what's happening here what is that
don't look like a guy oh it's a girl
drinking coffee it's a girl with
pigtails yeah oh it was a firefight yeah
huh unhand me you Beast
another memory what's gonna happen
Joe the Germania this game is awesome oh
we're in like a run like a nursery the
plant guy not the baby oh oh we broke a
plan
we broke somebody's plan her something
happened right let me knocked over a
plant yeah see one of the plants is like
knocked over Oh a bunch of the plants
are knocked over oh it's a living room
is living room with a lot of plants oh
oh the dad's yelling at us
Oh looks you were a little ballerina we
think we're ballerina oh look did you oh
you know what our brother knocked it
over and we're getting blamed for it
that's what happened our brother knocked
over a plant and by the way it's just
like a plant or a couple plants I guess
what's the big deal guys King kind of a
prick about it
where's the brother I know you're high
ah see ah
you could have helped instead you're a
jerk is he drawn there
Oh see you know what I bet oh he's
drying oh he picked it or something draw
them okay so he could draw them and
knocked it over we're getting blame for
him that's why the page had him drawing
in the plane
[Music]
so the dad's the monster
so you know the game is fiction because
it would have been my sister knocked
over the plant blame me and I would be
in trouble who did you little jerk
exactly time to fratricide exactly
killing for his crimes well what's this
I think we get this right we understand
what happened here
right yeah you're a dick you ruined this
for us
yeah dad is so not chill this game
should be called like dad has no chill
oh look let me go I wanna dance let me
dance let me dance I just wanna dance
let me dance away evil evil evil miss
before I am dancing got him up dance
whoo I could dance free again Oh time to
go back on the ribbon this is my
favorite part
[Music]
dance the power of dance is all around
you look at me dance the power of dance
it's all around us all we gotta do is
dance dance dance this is the biggest
fruit roll-up I've ever been on
whoo look at us sliding along this dance
dance dance away cuz we're dance it's
dance jazz hands
guys the power of jazz hands well what
do we learn this stream Coco we learned
Dada's no chill the power of dance can
overcome everything just dance guys
that's right that's right as you go
through this week if you have some
problems he's danced through him just
dance it out
you can that's right distract through
dance exactly
alright guys well thank you for joining
us for this this dancey installment of
stream Coco what our trip receives yeah
oh one of our trip history is one of our
dance your stream Dampier pretty fun
a lot more movement oh mom's upset
I didn't see what happened there oh it's
raining you know you're pregnant you
should go inside whatever
Wow let's go do it for ya you gotta stay
warm and you're pregnant a pseudo first
room cocoa the game is called bound it's
available now at my plastic studios
great job a great job plastics today's
game is super fun super weird
oh man I just spilled something on the
floor but you know what it's okay we're
gonna dance it out I'll see you guys
next Monday at noon for an all-new
stream cocoa see you guys later bye
you